also selbst noch nie in bremen gingen
spielen muss dann immer schwerer
den block zu haben
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einem sportboot
dem sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast zwei
beachvolleyball wir machen auch gleich
eine standkontrolle korporal robin seidl
hier gefragt philipp weil hier alle
anwesen das heißt wir können unseren
podcast loslegen mit robin und philipp
dem petra seidl weiter herzlich
willkommen und ihr seid ja auch schon um
mit oder in der vorbereitung in wenigen
tagen geht es los mit heim
europameisterschaft geht es ja erst mal
ganz gut wir haben jetzt gute
vorbereitungsphase gehabt und wir sind
eigentlich ready und man donnerstag gas
zu geben und was zu reißen bei der heim
europameisterschaft ihr habt ja auch
natürlich und mit gespannt das gesamte
beach volleyball turnier in tokio mit
verfolgt ihr habt natürlich auch das
ziel gehabt euch zu qualifizieren es hat
nicht gereicht aber ihr seid ja noch ein
junges team spielt noch nicht so lange
gemeinsam wie hat sie die ganze quali
phase als team erlebt für was eigentlich
sehr entspannt würde mal sagen für mich
war dass wir ganze aufstieg von meiner
ganzen karriere eigentlich sehr schnell
so richtig dann glaubt ja haben wir
schon irgendwie aber ihr habt mir selber
bewusst nur nicht laut auszusprechen das
ziel
also für mich war es erst herantasten
und natürlich wollte es dann unbedingt
aber am ende ist es leider nicht so
gekommen aber weder seine
jung also
schauen wir mal also paris würde mich
gern qualifizieren dann welche
erfahrungen haben sie mitgenommen aus
diesen ganzen quatsch prozess dass ein
beach volleyball alles recht kompliziert
und sehr nervenaufreibend wahrscheinlich
auch wenn man dann zum turnier hin kommt
immer weiß es gibt nur noch einen platz
vor und die ganze vorbereitung was hat
ja als team mitnehmen können
ja es war ein langwieriger prozess
eigentlich immer für mich waren es vier
jahre wo wir darauf hin trainiert aber
das ist 2020 dann bei olympia steht
dann bereite man sich vorn dann mit
cofidis natürlich alles anders das heißt
es ist noch ein jahr länger ich denke
dass uns die phase eigentlich gut getan
hat als team wir noch ein jahr länger
kommt um uns zu spielen um uns
vorzubereiten um fit zu sein wenn man
ray die sein sollen ist natürlich dann
sehr sehr bitter dass es sich über drei
rankings auf knapp über zwei plätzen mit
ausgang ist wo dann an zwei turniere
einfach gefehlt haben vielleicht kommt
bedingt es werden mehr angesetzt gewesen
wer weiß wie man danach töten und dann
über den kontakt auch gegen die die sich
schlussendlich qualifiziert haben knapp
ausgeschieden das war diese anlage würde
sagen und diesel bitter aber denkt als
team hat uns das noch einmal vielleicht
stärker gemacht und noch einmal mehr
zusammengeschweißt und noch einmal mehr
zeit geben um konstanter zu werden und
die letzten turniere war gut wir spielen
zurzeit recht konstant jetzt schauen wir
was wien mit uns machen kann philipp du
hast frage meint gedauert das
auszusprechen was du nicht nur natürlich
war es das ziel wenn es so eng wird und
wenn man sich dann denkbar hätten die
turniere stattfinden keine werk wird
nicht gewesen es hätte die ware ist das
etwas was in euren köpfen dann auch
platz findet oder muss man das auch
bewusst abschalten und da gar nicht
zulassen dass das auch kommt also bei
mir kommt es eigentlich derzeit noch
keiner darf bei mir ist es eher so dass
sie jedes jahr
wieder schritte macht und erfahrungen
sammeln wollen allerdings obama wird den
es früher schon gemacht ist einfach wir
die internationale karriere als früher
starten können wo immer denkt okay
vielleicht ist es jetzt der nächste step
wohl merke dass das ist es jetzt aber ja
das ist die wahre lage derweil noch
nicht und jetzt kommt wien robin dass es
vorher schon angesprochen ihr spielt
konstant oder ausgangslage ist eine gute
aber wie schaut sie auf eure gruppe wie
steht da die auslosung ja wir mit motor
um auf einzelner gruppen natürlich zeit
das stärkste team wahrscheinlich der
welt wie man die spiele zum finale in
tokio dann haben wir eigentlich gestern
die wir erkennen
20 19 finale in baden spielt oder was
220 volt ich war dort habe ich bewundert
kernenergie hat ein finale gegen
gehalten hat und auch gewonnen habt also
gratuliere ich hatte immer das recht das
turnier der service von 200 fans die
damals erlaubt dann haben sie schon
geputzt zum sieg würde sagen jetzt sind
es zweieinhalb tausend fans ich hoffe
die pushen uns wieder zum sieg also mal
schauen wie das wird auf jeden fall ein
spannendes spiel in wieren fehlender
vorbeizukommen und sich das anzuschauen
das wird auf jeden fall spektakel
herzliche setzung geht man in so ein
heim turnier hinein wie löste das im
team welche ziele man sich selbst macht
den vorschlag und dann nimmt man die
mitte oder wie funktioniert das genau
ich glaube dass wir das ja
unterschiedlich sind ist das eigentlich
schlussendlich gleich also für mich
immer also die ziele die aber sprechen
meistens unter dem die eigentlich im
kopf hab also ich würde mal sagen für
mich das erste ziel ist die gruppe zu
schaffen
am freitag kann man mindestens noch zu
spielen ja insgeheim hoffen natürlich
dass das man irgendwann medaillen macht
besseren event oder dieses mal
vielleicht schafft wenn man jetzt die
saison ja schon viele große teams klagen
glaube wir wissen dass man jeden
schlagen können und dass es weitergehen
kann wenn wir das auf den platz bringen
was wir kennen ja stimmt du dazu
ist es so ist es aus einer anderen
perspektive egal wir sind beide so
verbissen ehrgeizig dass wir wenn wir
dann kurz stehen alles tun damit er das
spiel bienen und umso mehr wird sein
schweißt werden umso mehr
zusammengeschweißt sind gehen wir den
weg gemeinsam und dann ist es richtig
schwer uns zu schlagen weil wir haben
wählen und so waren fokus haben dass wir
das umsetzen wollen und ja ich glaub ich
hoffe dass wir das auf dem platz bringen
können jetzt in wien weil dann ist es
echt unangenehm gegen uns spielen weil
wir einfach
nicht verlieren wollen da nämlich als
ich euch spielen gesehen habe dass das
tool zum beispiel da wirklich in jedem
block ohne rücksicht auf eigene verluste
gegangen bist und egal ob der ball jetzt
im gesicht landete auf den fingern
landet megawatt einfach voll hinein in
diesem jahr geht es den sieht man auch
in der spielweise wie er spielt das
jetzt auch brauchen aus dieser gruppe
heraus zu kommen aber es ist eine heim
europameisterschaft du hast schon einmal
ein großevent daheim gespielt noch mit
einem anderen partner visa ist diese
erfahrung wichtig dass man weiß wie so
was daheim überhaupt abläuft mit 200.000
zuschauern das wird unter den auflagen
und umständen natürlich gewaltig werden
wie wichtig weiß dass du das schon mal
erlebt hast denn grundsätzlich die
turniere die ja hannes jagerhofer in
wien veranstaltet beziehungsweise damals
klagenfurt sind immer einzigartig in
klagenfurt war es glaube ich 6000 fans
erlaubt und unterm strich war zwischen
8000 fans zittern im stadion waren weil
es aus allen nähten geplatzt ist dort
waren auch schon zweimal
europameisterschaften wo man mit uns an
die damals eigentlich recht gut
abgeschnitten haben und in wien auf der
donauinsel war natürlich die
weltmeisterschaft 20 17h unglaublich war
also wieder neues ambiente anders wie
klagenfurt und ja damals waren ich
glaube 10.000 leute erlaubt das heißt
das war auch unglaublich
und jetzt jetzt ist am heumarkt das
heißt es ist wieder anderes ambiente
aber es werden wieder so für fans
dahinter sein und die stimmung wird
glaube ich noch größer sein weil es ist
mehr arenen adeg aufgebaut es geht steil
nach oben die fans sind mehr das heißt
es wird noch einmal eine besondere
erfahrung werden und ich denke wenn man
da ein lauft dann weiß man warum aber
jeden tag so hart trainiert und warum
man den sport macht und warum man da
stehen will und das als auf sich nimmt
ich glaube wenn man mit dem gefühl
umgehen kann mit dieser mit diesem
überwältigenden denen gefühl dann dann
ist es schon gut dass man die auch darum
weil gemacht hat die schon gut wenn wir
das dann nutzen kann natürlich philipp
das vor kurzem auch aus der anderen
perspektive gemacht die erfahrung
nämlich gegen ein heim team zu spielen
das von den fans mit getragen wurde wie
schwer tut man sich da wirklich in den
entscheidenden punkten dann genau die
prozente veräußerungen die man
eigentlich bräuchte ja genauso wie mein
start gegen die schweizer
spielen dürfen am centre grad und ja
also das schon richtig merkt dass das
publikum die richtig gepusht hat und
immer noch extra energie gegeben hat
genau um solche entscheidenden punkte
dann zu machen glaube in dem spiel ist
es uns nicht gelungen langericht für uns
zu entscheiden leider aber ja dieses mal
war es anders herum machen und dass wir
die entscheidenden punkte machen kann
man sich da auch auf sowas verlassen
dass man weiß hier auch wenn es eng wird
und knapp wird wenn wir die leute im
rücken haben dann holen wir uns den
punkt egal ob die anderen nominell
besser sind wenn man das so sagen kann
überhaupt im sport dass er schwer
möglich aber kann man sich auf diesen
push verlassen also ich denke schon also
wie wir in wien jetzt zum gespielt haben
hat uns das eigentlich immer ein push
geben und die zuschauer sind echt
einzigartig in österreich weil sie sind
sehr positiv und unterstützt heim dienst
das heißt da ist verlass auf sie dass
sie auf jeden fall da sind auch wenn der
ein oder andere punkt nicht für uns
fällt und das gibt halt genau dem putsch
auch für lange rallies für engere alles
für den sieg schlussendlich als der bus
sollte auf jeden fall funktionieren und
da sein damit ihr dann auch eure ziele
ob die ausgesprochen oder
unausgesprochen dann auch wirklich
gemeinsam erreichen können aber lasst
uns an den anfang gehen ihrer
gemeinsamen zeit im beach volleyball ist
ja so dass man
sich je nach lebensabschnitt einen
partner sucht wird der gerade gut passt
nie war das bei euch wie habt ihr euch
gefunden von meiner seite neben bin über
umwege wieder zurück nach wien weil er
eigentlich immer lieber beachvolleyball
spiel teilweise in der halle habe dann
die möglichkeit aber gesehen in wien mit
trainieren zu können
und das war für mich irgendwie so dass
er gewusst habe wenn er mal in wien
wieder trainieren kann und dort an
stützpunkten er dann nehmen da überhaupt
war also es ist halt in österreich wenn
du in der steiermark spürst du das und
nationale turniere spielst und dann ja
also wie oft kommt es vor dass jetzt die
top teams aus österreich in österreich
auch wirklich spielen außer bei den
staatsmeisterschaften ist erst helfen
und dann haben wir einfach gewusst wenn
ihr wenn ihr einen partner haben will
der international spielt und dann muss
ich irgendwie in das blickfeld und das
papier nach wien kommen und dann war es
eigentlich mehr zufall glaube
als jetzt irgendwie ja bewusste
entscheidung darf also zuerst halt das
glück gehabt dass sie beim baden monster
damals einspringen dürfen christoph
dressler der verletzte nicht spielen
können und ja dann hat eigentlich recht
gut funktioniert das dann
ja dann zwei wochen später werden auch
ein auftritt von rovinj ob wir nicht
weiter mit dem spielen möchte und dann
war für mich ja das würde eigentlich
schon schon gern machen und da war
richtig cool family
trust schon mit mehreren partnern
zusammen gespielt nach welchen kriterien
sucht man sich denn einen passenden
partner aus wirst du das damals
irgendwie gemacht
gute frage
ja es hängt viel davon ab glaube wie
partner harmonieren am court welche
ziele sie haben welche ziele sie auch
sich vorstellen können und auch
formulieren und wie man auch mit
drucksituationen und druck umgehen kann
wer denkt dass in dem leistungssport
echt wichtige kriterien überhaupt wenn
man sich hohe ziele setzt das ist nicht
immer so leicht
und ja mit einem fehler das war dann
coole möglichkeit wirklich in baden das
einmal zu testen um zu schauen wie
harmonia ja wir haben von anfang an sehr
sehr gut harmoniert am court das heißt
irgendwie haben wir gleiche vorstellung
vom spiel gehabt gleiche ziele am court
dem jeden ball zu gewinnen und das match
zu gewinnen und dieser will er irgendwie
und diese idee vom spiel hat uns
verbunden
und dann aber gleich gesagt okay hier
spüren wir weiter und dann beim ersten
internationalen turnier haben glauben
gold kult
und das hat dann noch einmal bestätigt
dass die entscheidung eigentlich die
richtige war und dass wir wenn wir dann
unseren willen vereinen dass wir uns so
stark sind wenn man dann verstanden hat
okay dass das passt das funktioniert wir
gehen jetzt den weg an ich schaue dann
die gesamte vorbereitung oder die
zielsetzung oder die planung für die
nächsten jahre aus kann man da für die
nächsten zehn jahre planen oder macht
man das von saison zu saison mit einem
großen ziel wie kann sich das ungefähr
vorstellen sie sind jedoch verschiedene
aspekte die damit hineinspielen wie wie
läuft so was hat man für mich wollten
den olympia habe in riehen neuen kult
dann habe gedacht ja auf jeden fall will
er dabei sein ich will eine medaille
holen und wo wir zusammen kommen sand
das war ein paar monat bevor die
qualifikation begonnen hat das heißt das
hatte ich schnell gehen müssen da war da
siegt dann genau richtig dann haben uns
all blacks etabliert auf der bergtour
und haben dann sehr sehr gut gestartet
ein die olympia-qualifikation bis hin
zur weltmeisterschaft wo man neunten
platz geholt haben war vielleicht top
ten im olympia ranking das heißt das hat
eigentlich sehr sehr gut funktioniert
leider haben wir die konstante leistung
eigentlich nett über die eineinhalb
jahre halten können das heißt im kleines
loch kriegt über par monat wo an zwei
wichtige turniere waren die wir dann
nicht ganz so gut gespielt haben und das
hat uns dann eben an zwar platz aus die
top 15 und dann wollte man genau wieder
reinkommen da ist die fahne wieder
kommen dann ist im kommen aber
eigentlich plant man schon oder 'ich
plane von olympia das heißt jungs sagt
er oder ihr gesagt wir wollen zu olympia
wir machen das jetzt ja viele wie es mit
gezogen hat sagt ja er will das und so
war der plan und jetzt ist der zyklus
einmal vorbei das heißt wir setzen uns
jetzt nach der em nach die
staatsmeisterschaften zusammen und sagen
hier gehen wir auf paris los oder wie
schaut's aus was machen wir das heißt
ich brauche ich jetzt noch gar nicht
fragen ob er diese pläne schon gemacht
haben wir da schon entschieden hat
wahrscheinlich werden sie auch
persönliche gedanken gemacht haben wenn
man weiß dass unter normalen umständen
drucker sich aus gegangen wäre wird man
wahrscheinlich auch parisien angriff
nehmen um sich dieses ziel vielleicht
jetzt ein bisschen verspätet noch einmal
zu erfüllen gehe ich mit meiner annahme
korrekt davon aus oder liege ich ganz in
holz ich auf jeden fall also für mich
ist das wie vorausgesagt von jahr zu
jahr obwohl mehr lernen und mehr
erfahrung sammeln und ja das planen habe
bis jetzt immer den meistern überlassen
also auch wenn die coaches und so weiter
wie weil wir einfach egal in welchem
trainer kraft wenn bald wieder turniere
wir einfach mein bestes geben und
schauen dass es weiter geht weiter nach
oben geht und ja jetzt nach der saison
war dem jahr mal hinsetzen und schauen
was dann die dinge die mir wichtig sind
dass sie mir selber ein bisschen mehr
einbringen aber bis jetzt war es halt
erst kennenlernen von dem ganzen wie das
abläuft und jetzt schon langsam
glaube dass wir bereit sind das ja
selber sagt okay dass projekte in einem
jahr oder wie immer also auf jeden fall
werde weiter spielen glaube eigentlich
ja fix ihr verlag sie jetzt die
notwendigen jahre auch zusammen also
nicht gleich irgendwie nach dem
zusammenkommen die gerade beginnen man
diskutiert of pop in teamsportarten
vor allem einem kleinen team und damit
alles funktioniert eben am platz die
kommunikation natürlich passen muss dass
man sich verstehen muss aber wie es
außerhalb des platzes es gibt da auch
verschiedene typen manche die die auch
da eine gewisse
freundschaft brauchen andere die
brauchen das überhaupt nicht es gibt
auch viele geschwister die
zusammenspielen wo das natürlich das
komplexe system geschützt dass anwender
spielen wie ist das bei euch was ist
euch in diesem aspekt oft akkord wichtig
also mir ist wichtig dass wir uns auf
kommt einfach gut verstehen dass wir
einander vertrauen können und wissen
schlussendlich sind wir zahlen am court
wollen vollgas geben das heißt ich denke
verbringen jetzt außerhalb von gordon
nicht so viel zeit miteinander aber wir
wissen sobald was ist oder sobald
errichtung court wieder geht man von 400
dauer und stärke nutzen rücken und die
finde diese vertrauensbasis oder das
gefühl ja sehr wichtig in so einer beach
volleyball partnerschaft wie siehst du
das ja also ist es eigentlich ein
ähnlich
ja es sollte auf jeden fall harmonisch
ablaufen
ja schon für freundschaft darauf kopf
also ich glaube es uns wäre es einfach
schwer und
wir verbringen hat doch sehr viel zeit
miteinander wir fliegen aber trotzdem
noch gemeinsam also es ist nicht so dass
wir jetzt getrennt flüge buchen um
extrem wenig miteinander zu machen und
wir teilen uns eigentlich großteils das
hotel und ja da ist es einfach wichtig
dass man sich gut versteht also ich
finde wir verstehen uns sehr gut auf
court auch also es ist immer sehr
harmonisch wir machen teils auch road
trips zu trainieren oder wenn es sich
ausgeht bleiben andere anzahl tag länger
und entspannen zu haben also das ist
jetzt eigentlich ist die zeit die man
sehr angenehm die man gemeinsam
verbringen das ist warum ich frage weil
es das halt so spannendes welche aspekte
der wahl mit hineinspielen und dann im
endeffekt eigentlich erfolg oder
misserfolg mit beeinflussen österreich
war in den letzten jahren im
beach-volleyball
sehr erfolgreich wir hatten immer wieder
sehr starke leistungen ob jetzt die
frage schwestern oder
clemens und alex warum ist österreich
auch spielerisch aber vor allem auch
event seit ich so gut im
beach-volleyball obwohl wir in dem sinne
wenig natürlich strand zur verfügung
haben dass man sagt die kinder wachsen
mit beach-volleyball auf ist gute frage
also ich glaube österreich war einst
wenigen nationen die zwei herrenteams
über bei olympia gehabt haben und da
denkt man sich wehren kann strand werden
eigentlich nichts warum genau österreich
denkt im beach volleyball sind
charaktere extrem wichtig das bedeutet
dass
er charakter mehr ausmacht dass er am
strand zu haben das heißt wenn du die
richtigen athleten findet die charakter
mitbringen und das vollgas ins spital
weil rein investieren oder den sport
rein investieren dann kann es am tag
sehr weit nach oben gehen und ich denke
dass da in österreich scheinen doch gut
selektiert oder dass man sich doch gut
durchsetzen kann in österreich wenn man
charakter hat und
so dann schlussendlich erfolgreich ist
irgendwie in dieser sportart und also in
dieser
komischen situationen mit der
abhängigkeit voneinander von einer
anderen person muss soll doch irgendwie
was ja ich glaub an charakter haben um
zu zeigen hey da bin ich oder da will
ich hin oder da wollen wir hin und das
ist im beachvolleyball anfang echt große
rolle du hast auch verschiedene
sportarten gemacht beförderte ich dann
im endeffekt für volleyball und
beachvolleyball entschieden hast warum
genau beachvolleyball
yaman ich bin eben wird das sagen
endlich wieder viel da reingeschlittert
ins beach volleyball gibt damals wo ihr
recht jung war und ich glaub 23 jahren
betreiber über das gespielt habe angebot
von xandi huber kriegt dass wir
gemeinsam spielen und wir waren
eigentlich sofort erfolgreich und ich
grundsätzlich liebe sport ich liebe
bälle
ehrgeizig das heißt kann man nichts
schöneres vorstellen als am court zu
stehen im wettkampf zu haben und mit dem
ball zu spielen das heißt ihr glaubt
dass das das schon meine motivation war
um da weiter gas zu geben und den sport
zu lieben wie war das bei dir philipp
wie bist du zum beach volleyball
gekommen doch warum genau die
entscheidung für das beach volleyball
spielen naja gute frage
mir war zuerst alle anderen
ballsportarten aber quer durch
begonnen natürlich mit fußball über
basketball dann im hallen volleyball
eigentlich schon der hib liebenau in der
akademie gewesen
und dort ja in der halle eingespielt und
ja das
hat man immer extrem darauf dass
volleyball aber wollten mehr bieten wir
dann irgendwie spürt zu hey das ist ok
in vino mehr als halle das passt einfach
bei jedem ballwechsel an anteil du bist
einfach auf die allein gestellt und oder
auf bei denen eigentlich es gibt kein
auswechselspieler und du musst das
einfach machen und das hat man irgendwie
sofort zugesagt und gibt dann bei den
junioren em und wm das match mittel
dürfen gern mal und das war schon
anreiz dann aber weiter zu machen und
ich finde das ist einfach extrem coole
sport und ja ich würde mich sofort
wieder dafür entscheiden glaube ich
glaube das werden sie
höchstwahrscheinlich bei robin du hast
auch einen spitznamen frank dutchman wie
sie zu dem gekommen den klang wird
gewesen
habe recht gut blockiert bin recht hoch
gesprungen am block und generell und
meine mutter ist holländerin das heißt
ich bin halb holländer
und der floristik damals der sprecher
hat das natürlich gewusst und so sieht
man dann oder so hat er mir dann halt
ausgerufen the flying dutchman und das
hat sich durch gezogen bis jetzt sogar
jetlags aprile der flying dutchman macht
hat
man also meine brille ist sozusagen die
beach welt davon zu überzeugen dass der
flasche mit einfach recht hoch springt
und die sonnenbrille auf das bringt
ja das schon echt cool als ich bin stolz
drauf holländer zu sein ein bin aber
stolz darauf für österreich zu spielen
und ja das freut mich sehr dass spitzen
und wenn du sagst solche spitznamen
entstehen dann auch geben die auch ein
bisschen eine art
also respekt bei den gegnern dass die
wissen ja wenn der ist so weit bringt
dass man ihn schon fliegens nennt weil
er halt so hoch hüpfte ist etwas wo dann
die anderen sich auch gedanken machen
wie sie gegen dich spielen weil sie
wissen dass du halt sehr bekannt ist ja
schon also ich bin öfter auf der tour
schon ein bisschen bekannt dass sie sehr
sehr variantenreich und block bin sehr
spät springen uns sehr schnell oben bin
ich würde schon sagen dass das ein
effekt hat und die wissen die meisten
wissen dass sie halb holländer bin und
wissen sie wir fragen darin heißt es das
ist schon sehr cool wenn ihr jetzt kurze
an die stärken des anderen denkt das ist
eine stärke heraus pointiert was würdest
du sagen macht das spiel von philipp aus
ich würde sagen da viel ist extrem
ehrgeiziger sowie der wirtschaftsfaktor
starken willen was in drucksituationen
was in spanien situation in scheinen
phasen extrem wichtig und von vorteil
ist und ich finde da geniale übersicht
und trifft extrem gute entscheidungen im
angriff das bedeutet es ist extrem
schwer in der taktik gegen ihn zu
spielen weil er sie schnell durchschaut
aber die übersicht hat und die technik
das umzusetzen und so ihr denkt dass das
so die stärken sind philipp was sagst du
überall
[Gelächter]
so daraufhin kennt einfach erstmal jedes
team kennt man sport und ist ja
einfacher taktikfuchs also da hat er es
nicht nur varianten block sondern maße
die variante einzusetzen und waren das
ist ja
eigentlich ein guter punkt weil wenn man
variantenreiches zur falschen zeit
einsetzt dann ist es wahrscheinlich dazu
effekt effektiv aber das macht auf jeden
fall extrem gut zusätzlich block der
extrem stark hat einfach ein
unglaubliches dahinter also selbst noch
nie im training gegen ihn spielen muss
dann doch immer schwerer den
block zu haben
und ja wir
haben also einige stärken also schon
gehört auch von robin auch von dir
philipp ihr habt jetzt auch das training
kurz angesprochen da spielt man ja auch
gemeinsam mit anderen mannschaften mit
anderen trainingspartnern jetzt fällt
doch auf dass in österreich eben nicht
nur ihr nicht nur clemens und alex
bekannt sind und erfolgreich sind
sondern auch andere meiner mannschaft
noch damenmannschaften wie wichtig ist
diese interne konkurrenz dass man sich
auch im training messen kann dass man
weiß dass man vielleicht nicht immer
gesetzt ist für die turniere weiter zwei
drei andere auch noch lauern um die
startplätze ist das etwas was auch daran
gegenseitigen pusch gibt oder hinter
dass die eigene entwicklung eigentlich
mehr ich denke im training ist extrem
wichtig dass das der teams geht die
ähnlich gut sind teils auf augenhöhe
sind einfach um enge situationen zu
kreieren um wirklich in drucksituationen
zu kommen ansonsten spielt man halt
gewinnt man hat als den focus dass man
das team locker schlägt und drüber fährt
man kommt wenigen situation wo es der
letzte punkt entscheidet wo es wirklich
spannend wo es ums eingemachte geht und
da tut man es doch extrem gut denke dass
man da wirklich dann auch sie in
situationen sind wo man teils
überfordert sind wo man teils den druck
verspüren wo man teils kann aus wie
kommen wo man lösungen finden müssen und
das ist im beach-volleyball extrem
wichtig weil irgendwann kommt man in
drucksituationen wo man genauso dann
lösungen finden muss wo man dann ruhig
bleiben muss wo man dann an step ahead
sein muss und ich denke das pusht uns
ziemlich alles schon echt coole
gemeinschaft die man dann auf jeden fall
sind die voraussetzungen so gelegt damit
er erfolgreich sein kannst alles gute
für die heim-europameisterschaft die
bald losgeht und natürlich auch für eure
weitere zukunft denke dass wir heute mit
dabei war
ja danke auch dass ihr mit dabei war bis
zum nächsten mal beim sport report bis
dann servus
[Musik]
[Applaus]